concentration précision et savoir-faire
les ingénieurs d'Astrium travaille à la
fabrication de réflecteurs satellite la
filiale aéronautique de ADS installée au
Murau est l'une des 10 entreprises
mondial qui maîtrisent cette technologie
complexe il faut en effet que ces
paraboles de 2,6 m de diamètre
installées sur les satellites de
télécommunication renvoie correctement
les données en d'autres termes les
ingénieurs doivent faire en sorte que
l'inform envoyé au satellite soit
redirigé sur Terre à l'endroit voulu ce
ne sont pas des paraboles parfaites ce
sont des surfaces formées avec des
bosses des creux ces formes permettent
de d'avoir la la France l'Espagne et de
ne pas viser par exemple l'océan
atlantique mais d'avoir les Canaris par
exemple une fois équipé de réflecteur qu
en moyenne le satellite est envoyé en
orbite géostationnaire à 36000 km de la
Terre par des lanceurs comme Arian 5
fabriqué aussi au Murau et à cette
distance les conditions météo sont très
variables quand on envoie nos matériels
ils peuvent être
déformés à cause des températures par
exemple si on envoie un morceau
d'aluminium dans l'espace avec il va se
dilater quand il va arriver à plus 165°g
et il va se restreindre énormément quand
il va être à mo-0°gr pour éviter cette
déformation l'utilisation du carbone les
paraboles sont fabriqués en matériaux
composite pour développer un réflecteur
il faut compter entre 7 et 9 mois depuis
le dessin à la réalisation des essais en
passant par la fabrication 70 salariés
travaillent dans ce département et des
projets innovants sont en cours comme
des réflecteurs à double bande de
fréquence capable de renvoyer un plus
grand nombre
d'information